Hey guys, Matt here for Science or Fiction.
Flying to far off destinations and exploring
a new city is great, except for the jet lag
you inevitably get after you land.
But that’s just flying, right?
It's not like you can just make a plane that
magically gets rid of all the physical effects
of traveling through the sky at around 35,000
feet for several hours.
That’s just some crazy fantasy that none
of us will experience in our lifetimes…
it says that right there next to me doesn't it. Yeah, thought so.
If you’ve ever been on a long flight across
multiple time zones, you have probably experienced
the unfortunate symptoms of jet lag.
Simply put, jet lag is a temporary sleep disorder
that typically occurs when you cross two or
more time zones.
And there’s a pretty easy explanation as
to why it happens.
When you take off from one time zone and land
in another, your body’s circadian rhythms
can’t just magically adapt, because your
body still thinks you are in the time zone
from which you came.
This can leave you feeling irritable, tired,
and it can even cause stomach problems.
Fortunately, it is temporary.
It varies from person to person how long the
symptoms last, but typically it takes a day
per time zone crossed before your body can
adapt to the new rhythm.
But if you are going on a shorter trip, it
can also put a major kink in your travel plans.
I mean, who wants to get all the way to Berg
en and be too tired to explore the exciting,
second-largest city in Norway?
Don’t you want to see this bird?
How about this rack of sweaters?
Now despite what this article seems to say,
there is no total cure for jet lag (some things
just require time, guys), but Boeing has designed
a plane that can minimize its symptoms by
using air pressure and increased humidity.
Most planes are currently pressurized to simulate
the conditions a person would feel at 6 to
8,000 feet, which isn’t bad considering
that most planes fly between 30 and 40 thousand
feet.
But 8,000 feet is still a pretty high altitude
that can lead to symptoms like headache and
nausea, similar to what’s called “altitude
sickness”.
The Boeing 787 Dreamliner family of airplanes
is pressurized to a new maximum level of 6,000
feet; 2,000 feet lower than most other aircraft.
Altitude chamber tests show that because the
body absorbs 8% more oxygen into the blood
at this altitude, passengers experience fewer
headaches and less dizziness and fatigue.
That lower cabin pressurization is possible
due to increased use of composites.
These new Airplanes are 50 percent composite
by weight.
Carbon fiber reinforced polymer, also known
as CFRP, resists fatigue and corrosion more
than traditional metals used to build planes,
and therefore allows for more internal pressurization.[1]
CFRP also means that planes can withstand
more humidity.
Metal can corrode when exposed to humid air,
but that’s not as much of an issue with
the new material.
Now, that matters to you because, while you
might not notice a change in humidity in the
moment, you likely will notice that your throat,
eyes, and nose are less dry when you land.
Now, again, these engineering changes don’t
cure jet lag, but the lower cabin pressurization
and increased humidity will make you feel
more comfortable during your trip to Bergen.
That being said, I’d sleep on the plane
if you can.
Unfortunately, there’s still no total cure
for jumping time zones.
For more epic stories of innovation that shaped
our future check out THE AGE OF AEROSPACE.COM
Can you get jet lag flying on a helicopter?
I guess then it wouldn’t be jet lag.
Helicopter-lag?
I know you would get a headache because helicopters
are super loud but did you know that there’s
such a thing as a stealth helicopter.
It’s a thing, check it out here.
And as always, please like and subscribe and
keep coming back to Seeker for more videos.